un père mastic plume à stoke
le plus pervers qu'il ne fait pas bon
tomber entre les griffes des deux à
perdre aux descentes de police leurs
victimes vous le verrez s'en rendra
compte très vite cette semaine c'est
karen cheryl disque d'or dans une bonne
douzaine de pays
karen cheryl présentatrice vedette sur
tf1 qui reçoit la visite de nos deux un
père fouettard là là pouf l'appel telle
est en panne
comment tu te rappelles je peux vous
offrir un poste radio si vous riez aussi
le mans tout apple comment je m'appelle
oui on t'écoute poupée eh bien je veux
pas car ils cheryl non ça c'est pas vrai
on sait qu'il a trouvé ça ce nom de
clown ridicule or j'ai une imagination
débordante
trouvez-vous c'est pas ton johnny storm
qui trouvait ça et vous lui aussi un
grand méchant trouvé ça tout seul allez
vas-y
qu'est-ce que trouver je suis tout
salaire qu'est ce que tu trouves ça
qu'est-ce qu'a trouvé ça mais je vous ai
dit que j'avais une imagination
absolument débridée talent et surnom au
oui ça m'arrive nord charente fait pas
partie du cercle des intimes alors ton
nom de famille plus 10 pour moi non on
va le dire sont vraiment oui si vous me
demandez gentiment je m'appelle isabelle
morizet isabelle moins ridicule que qu'à
réduire les bruits je t'appelle pas
isabelle mon état d'un bond il quoi non
plus il a un problème de pointe
sociation dites moi votre petit copain
pour les interrogatoires et la fatigue
alors c'est sûr non mais sur le
nord-isère bébé par exemple les bébés
plus gros bébé
ep puis le lit car la grosse de l'état
et puis et puis des myopes ou quoi les
lunettes
et puis quoi d'or et puis et puis qu'est
ce que vous voulez mais le vrai surnom
le vrai surnom le voit sur non j'ai pas
envie de vous lire on accouche lolita
ckoi vulcaine
oui là où vous devriez demander après
logement s'ils sont insalubres aux
locaux
alors tenez ou d'envié modèle d'école
faillite cheryl je suis né je suis né
par une très belle après midi d'été ont
devant leur camp devant il ya 27 ans de
cela dans une ville sublime avec
monument je ne vais pas concernant les
bons oeufs ni quand tu as quel âge est
souvent attaqué là je lui dis 27 tank 27
ans pas plus non
oui elle est finalement très bien j'aime
bien alors mettez mesure mais je mesure
1 mètre soixante dix avec le chignon
avec la choucroute mais c'est à dire que
je fais quand même beaucoup plus que
vous sans vous talonnettes et tour de
saintdo béton bien terrible hugo
l'opération ben suite serait levé tant
que témoin gerald ciolek mensurations
mensurations idéales ton vert glauque
lasserai pas d'intérêt les yeux mon
verre globale au mythique unique les
postes des lentilles soulever reviendra
en ondes que tu mettes sur les yeux
merci du compliment
non c'est un complément des regrets
tu as du goût vous offrir les verts
huîtres couleur blond numéro 12 s'est
déjà les montres à l'est par le nez
maintenant on va les aider faire faire
mal et déjà c'est pas sans monnaies
c'est vrai mais tu verras liausson
souviens tu te fait refaire le nez déjà
une fois ce que je pourrais pas laisser
la place d'albon chirurgie esthétique
effectivement une fois je dois beaucoup
à ma mère je la remercie d'ailleurs de
le faire faire tomber ou pas tous les
printemps
donc tu seras bien et qu'ils
continueront à faire un échantillon
comme ça ou non vous verrez demain on
aura des réunions se donnent rendez-vous
quand je serai vieille tu que tu feras
charge très bien ouais et passe le
regarderai la télé parce que je vous y
verrez qu annonce assez sûr de lui
porter bagel 20 ans tu vois la chirurgie
esthétique ou pas faute commence à voir
des fois des diffuseurs vite que
maintenant tu commenceras grosse et en
voir plus que maintenant tu vois que tu
veux comme tu l'écris cure c'est surtout
rien changer comme ça marche vraiment tu
vois les laissez moi ouais pourquoi
qu'elle aura aventure à la télé avec des
rideaux non j'espère que je tiendrais du
dinosaure se doit de bien fier de mes
rides et l'expérience des maisons mal
fini le dinosaure qu'est-ce qu'ils aient
ton papa il vous nourrissait c'est à
dire mais c'est à dire qu'il était
agriculteur très bien où ça en normandie
dans cannes ça doute vie sa part 1 on
s'y fait quoi à karel mais oui on aime
bien qu'à jerez les pauvres et les
basiques reine des pommes résidente à
elle est banale elle est digne de vous
votre talent en ces termes elle concerne
l'infirmerie garde ses frères et lui dit
non tu as d'autres vies cela par la
chanson fut par exemple parce que tu
fais tu fais jamais fait pour moi tu
fume pas toi tu bois même temps tu bois
jamais d'alcool
tu vois pas table pourquoi pas toi tu
vois quoi table un tout petit verre de
très bons vins exceptionnellement on va
en gagner un très bon dîner 1 gb
d'alcool rien peut pas toujours de la
riponne whisky pas de charge et le
martini dry tu sais ce que c'est martine
et brad
à mon avis vous savez j'ai pensé à
compter de monde
oui alors à part ça est ce que tu as
déjà fumer des pétards non tout
simplement pourquoi pourquoi tout
simplement parce que moi je suis
naturellement bien éclaté dans ma tête
et ça se voit
il n'a pas vraiment très très bien joué
d'après le parquet le bizarre de dire à
l'ordre aient jamais fumé tu préfère
prendre de la cocaïne dans les studios
table de la cocaïne dans les studios
soit 12 de la cauquenne n'amuse pas du
tout quand on a chopé tout à l'heure en
bas la cocaïne erreur c'était une boîte
de poudre car on pense d'un congrès
peut-être gauche ou de droite je survole
tu as déjà voté oui c'est toujours
molles pas si tu veux tard à chaque fois
tu votes oui à 80 a voté par exemple je
suis une
je suis une petite française extrêmement
fidèle à toutes les traditions civique
peut les convictions politiques comme et
les convictions politiques
elle a des convictions politiques gens
dont je ne parlerai pas les groupes
tu as voté pour mitterand je sais que tu
as voté pour but la peur d'un contrôle
fiscal fait ça c'est fait à quel âge
celui qui fut le premier le premier
votre faute
ouais le premier coup de foudre les
premiers bouts de foot d'abord je pas
envie de vous dire à quel âge
ça commence à sentir les garçons et
qu'elle a flirté le premier coup de
foudre s'était en fait à l'amour tout ce
qu'il y avait de plus pure est à la mode
enfant moi ma tête
alors après la bêta écrire des poèmes je
veux c'est quitter pas dans la tête et
dans le corps a beaucoup plus tard comme
alors raisonnable c'est-à-dire avant 20
ans avant 20 ans combien d'années avant
20 ans très peu d'années avant 20 ans
très peu du jugement afin 18-17 à 3,17 à
nyon 18 18 ans tu commences à coucher
avec des garçons 18 à nantes vous l'avez
poser une question qui était différente
et qu'on a fait lors des 18 ans et bien
embrasser le bout des doigts
c'est bien
ça y est comme moi et a connu comme
rabat est connu comme un garçon bon très
très peu je suis les consommateurs
fidèles par les comptes est encore jeune
quand même garçon pas le genre exemple
un geste plutôt 5 10 20 je fais les
compter sur la même note aaa est ce que
tu sais ce que c'est que le point g
et bien moi j'ai envie de vous répondre
que le poids gc le centre de gravité
grave tu es plutôt vaginale ou
clitoridienne comme clients
oui je trouve plutôt à british quand on
est fille de fermiers on sait ce qu'on
fait de son blé en général
qu'est ce que tu avais on est pauvre
j'ai une autre au soudan a lancé un
volontaire courage totalement
involontaire le jeu de mots quand on
écrit les fermions c'est ce qu'ont fait
200 b 1 que c'était en fait tomber deux
onglets dur qu'est ce que tu fais de
tombes les entraînements je leurs
plantes pour qu'ils pouvaient s'achète
de la guerre il est vrai qu'au début
j'ai de la peine ça en tout cas je
m'achèterai pas la même affaire
pitoyable
bravo et merci à karen cheryl davin jeu
de jeu surtout d'avoir survécu à cette
descente de police le retour des deux
impairs lors d'une prochaine draft
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu